una muestra de apoyo del secretario
general de la otan James toltenberg
visitó kiev por primera vez desde que
estalló la guerra durante el curso del
conflicto ha mantenido un peligroso
equilibrio entre lograr que los estados
miembros suministren armas a Ucrania
mientras evita que la organización
militar resulte directamente involucrada
debemos continuar fortaleciendo las
fuerzas armadas de Ucrania y debemos
asegurarnos de que existen arreglos
sólidos y poderosos para la seguridad de
Ucrania el lugar que le corresponde a
Ucrania está en la otan y con el tiempo
nuestro apoyo lo ayudará a hacer lo
posible
los funcionarios en Moscú a menudo se
refieren a la Guerra de Ucrania como un
conflicto de poder con la otan una
acusación que el secretario general y
los países niegan recientemente
Dinamarca y Países Bajos se convirtieron
en los últimos miembros de la alianza en
anunciar tanques para Ucrania el anuncio
se produce cuando los funcionarios en
kiev continú más armamentos
el retraso en el suministro de armas
significa que estamos perdiendo tiempo
para alcanzar la paz y las tropas
ucranianas que no obtienen las
herramientas para luchar pagan el precio
queremos entender cuando Ucrania será
miembro de la otan También queremos
garantías de seguridad en Nuestro camino
hacia la membresía en la otan Ucrania
solicitó unirse a la otan en septiembre
pasado buscando enviar un mensaje claro
a Moscú quien Espera que su solicitud se
acelerada sin embargo la cuestión ha
dejado a la organización dividida a los
miembros del flanco Oriental les
gustaría un gesto simbólico de Ucrania
en la próxima cumbre de la otan en julio
sin embargo mientras la guerra continúe
es poco probable que suceda